Elon Musk has bought Twitter I think
because he has realized that Twitter is
the network of among all the social
networks that is closest to a global
brain
it's totally mind-blowing to realize
that he basically trades a bunch of Rosy
stock for the opportunity to become Pope
pope of a religion that has more active
participants than Catholicism even right
daily practitioning people who enter
this church and think together and it's
a thing that is completely incoherent at
this point almost and completely
incorrect the bubbles of sentience but
for the most part this thing is just
screeching at itself
and now the SD question can we fix the
incentives of Twitter to turn it into a
global brain
and a Elon Musk is global brain build he
believes that this is the case and
that's the experiment that he is trying
to do which makes me super excited right
this might fail is a very big chance
that it fails but there is also the
chance that we get the global brain that
we get go emerging collective
intelligence it is working in real time